when you think of Bioshock games you
probably also think of lead designer Ken
Levine so why did he leave the franchise
Rolling Stones new gaming site click
soul sat down to interview Levine about
this and why he moved on to develop
smaller more experimental games when
talking about the last entry BioShock
Infinite he stated I saw a picture of me
when we first announced it that was 2010
and then I saw a picture of me after I
did an interview on NPR when we shipped
it in 2013 and I look 10 years older I
think the natural expectation was that I
would go and do the next bigger and
better Bioshock game and I felt I think
I'll fail if I do that I think I'll lose
my mind and my marriage and so my
solution was to quit publisher 2k hasn't
officially announced anymore Bioshock
games but you can still replay the
original trilogy Bioshock the collection
is available now on ps4 and Xbox one and
it comes to PC tomorrow September 16th
to keep up with whatever Ken Levine does
next you're already in the right place